and finally new rule the next time we
have a worldwide pandemic we have to
come up with a better solution then
everyone becomes Howie Mandel
you know Howie I know Howie who doesn't
love Howie the world's most famous
germaphobe who was social distancing
before it was cool well now of course
everybody's making the joke that Howie
Mandel had it right all along
no Howie would be the first to tell you
he has a disease OCD that [ __ ] up your
life he can't touch a doorknob or wear
shoes with laces cuz they might touch
the ground when he excuses himself to go
to the bathroom it's to clean it no
wonder he says it was always a curse
that behavior didn't allow me to date or
go out with anybody when I was young or
really even have friends
he also said I'm always on the verge of
death in my head I worry that the past
two months of quarantine have given
people the idea that the way for humans
to win our million-year war with
microbes is to avoid them completely and
I'm here to tell you you can't the key
to beating Kovan isn't dining through
glass or never going to a concert or a
ballgame again
it's your immune system you hear people
say Cove it 19 is a new virus so the
immune system doesn't know how to handle
it
[ __ ] of course it does that's why
the vast majority of people have had it
either recovered or didn't even know
they had it what do you think did that
the human immune system know there are
people with immune systems that can't do
the job and we should make it a priority
to protect those people but compulsively
washing being scared of your own hands
that can't become the new normal in his
later years when he was peeing into jars
and wearing Kleenex boxes for shoes we
pitied Howard Hughes because it was
pitiful in the 70s they made a TV movie
with John Travolta about a sick kid
called the boy in the plastic bubble
and let me tell you if they start
selling these things on Amazon we're in
trouble
III see there's a hot new item for sale
online disinfecting shoe mats cuz kovat
can get on your feet yes it can get
everywhere microbes are ubiquitous you
can keep discovering new places to scare
people into buying protection for but
we're solving the problem from the wrong
end this is a health problem we can't
sanitize the universe governor's should
declare keeping our bodies in good
health an essential job because that's
the only way we are going to win this
we've all read the articles your sink as
500,000 bacteria per square inch your
toothbrush as feces on it eco lies been
found in makeup carpets bedding the
remote cutting boards the average pillow
has 350,000 bacterial colonies they're
filled with more [ __ ] than the guy
selling them your phone has 10 times the
bacteria of your toilet which your dog
drinks out of and then licks you I could
see right over there right now one of my
dogs lying on the driveway like a dead
[ __ ] fly the driveway where cars
would god-knows-what on their tires pull
in and then that idiot rolls in it and
the other one I don't know where he is
which means he's into something worse
sometimes I see a dead mouse in the
driveway I don't have a cat something
here killed it I'm not pointing fingers
but there's only the three of us my
point is God knows what is all over your
pets and in their mouth and then you
invite them on the bed and they try to
french kiss you and sometimes succeed
and some people don't even fight it but
what's the point of a pet if you're not
going to pet it it's in the name and
what's the point of life if you can't
live it have you
had sex in a hotel did you wash your
hands first well the last couple didn't
either and yet you're still alive
because your immune system said we got
this so this weekend do something nice
for your immune system go outside that
mysterious land beyond your curtains
where the GrubHub drivers live and get
some fresh air and vitamin D and break a
sweat doing something besides eating hot
chicken because at the end of the day
you can't keep all the pathogens out it
would be as silly as thinking you could
stop immigration with a wall
you